have the photo of her flying in the p-51
with me
yes she sure did she unbelievable
you know what i never told i was afraid
to tell
tom at the time was i had just recently
come out of sort of like decided to out
think my
think myself out of a really crippling
fear of flying that i
suffered from for years
and so originally when i signed on to do
the movie there was no flying from my
character my character was on land she
was on the water she was never in the
air
there was a scene at at one point where
we were it's like on
taxing on a runway maybe in a plane
together
so tom and i are shooting that scene and
the plane the p-51 it's like tiny here
like the
top of the cockpit is right here my
knees are up against his back and
he's like wow you ever jenna you ever
been in a in a plane like this before i
was like
no no i i haven't tom it's amazing
like ever done any aerobatic flying
before i was like starting to get
nervous
no why
will i be doing something he's like it's
gonna be very graceful
very elegant just some very elegant
roles
you know it's gonna be nice and easy
so yeah that's how i found out that i
was gonna be up in the p-51 with tom
flying it
and miles tell me this when you signed
up for this did you know that there
wouldn't be green screen did you know
that this was all going to be
proper g-force and and real um
yeah i think that was i think that was
somewhere in the fine print somewhere no
i mean
i i did i did absolutely but i
i absolutely underestimated
the training that it would take to be
able to withstand
um you know the g forces that we're you
know
pulling you know people are throwing up
you know
in the cockpit fairly often like it is
it is no joke to
get in those jets and we're making top
gun you know so we're never going around
sightseeing it's it's very intense like
what miles said i told you
i said and i shot the early test i
i showed you the early
i told you i said and i even shot
first and i showed you the footage show
me the email
you